hallo zusammen das ist ein affrong gegen
applewar pictures im Fragenlotto gibt es
nämlich so gut wie keine grünen fragen
wie reagieren die beiden drauf das sieht
er jetzt und noch viel mehr im
Fragenlotto viel Spaß dabei
davon habt ihr schon gehört oh ja das
Tragen Lotto es gibt gute
nein es gibt nur eine gute
er muss noch erklären was ich weiß nicht
nur diese hier sind die blöden Fragen
die gemein und die grüne hier die eine
grüne eine grüne hier das ist die nette
Frage die heben wir uns mal für ganz zum
Schluss auf der krachten wir greifen
dann jetzt mal rein und fangen direkt an
jetzt schon die erste Frage ich muss sie
jetzt mal überlegen wie ich das andere
wäre weil normalerweise die guten Fragen
es gibt ja nur eine der Plural fällt da
weg
warum sind eigentlich so kacke auch nein
ähm wann verlassen diese Hausbesitzer
endlich Chance von einem Nachbarn
gefragt
ach so diese beiden Hausbesitzer jetzt
schon quasi die wohnen ja bei uns ja und
die ganzen Mercy ja immer sind ja ja die
wohnen auch alle bei uns
das macht ja auch alles klar die werden
wir nicht mehr los mach doch alles gar
keine räumlichen Probleme weil es ja eh
Internet da passt ja alles rein ja genau
ja wir wohnen ja auch alle zusammen
genau im Internet im Internet
aber ganz ehrlich nervt das nicht
wirklich manchmal man möchte auch
einfach mal ins Bett fallen
es ist
manchmal echt der Fall also ganz ganz
selten so seine Sache kommen dieses
Wochenende das nächste Woche Ende dann
ist wieder eine Veranstaltung das
Wochenende danach das Wochenende und
dann denke ich mir einfach mal nee jetzt
dieses Wochenende nee nee und selbst
dann kommen noch ein oder zwei dann
kommt man vorbei oder so oh das sind
dann so so Leute wo ich mir denke okay
oder dann stellt man hier Tommy
irgendeine an eine andere
okay
aber die Frage war doch noch gar nicht
dran
nein dann ist das ja in Ordnung meine
Freundin da ansonsten ab und zu aber
irgendwie dafür haben wir noch unter der
Woche Zeit ja okay unter der Woche
darf ich jetzt ziehen du darfst auch
sehen so die musst du aufmachen du hast
ein bisschen jetzt irgendeine Scheiße
gezogen ja
die Farbe anders
warum fallen uns zu euch so wenig grüne
Fragen ein
ich glaube das hat
wir müssen bei der redaktisch
rüberkommen wenn wir solche Fragen
bekommen oder wegkommen
ich weiß es nicht vielleicht war auch
das grüne Papier leer ich weiß nicht
reaktionell so abläuft das rosane war
billiger
ich weiß es nicht ich hoffe mal nicht
weil wir euch so unsympathisch machen
die werden sich nicht beschweren
ansonsten sind sie direkt wieder raus
hier nach dem Motto wir drücken Youtube
kündigungs- die werden schon alles
mitmachen
klar wir haben nur rosane fragen wer
hätte es gedacht das kommt ich habe noch
keine sexistische oder sonst irgendwas
gelesen noch gar nicht ja
wann macht ihr endlich mal witzige
Videos
vielleicht im nächsten Leben oder so
oder wir machen eine neue Chance
da kommt dann ein Video tun uns
sorry
haben wir verstanden
ich dachte eine Banane in die Haare
gewesen
niemals damit ihr auch immer von ganz
weiten sehen könnt über diesen blonde
Streifen damit ihr auch mal von ganz
weiten sehen könnt
so
läuft das ist ein Markenzeichen halt ja
da müsste von vorne rein dann könnte 10
m rum gehen nicht dass ich spontan
können so ganz genau
du musst rausziehen
lässt uns alle Fragen ziehen
wie kommt man als Nerd an so eine süße
Freundin
Verzweiflung
so verzweifelt sieht sie gar nicht aus
genau
ja ich habe früher habe ich immer
gedacht so wenn ich so einen hübschen
hübsche Frau
weißt du so ein Scheiß Typ mit so einer
hübschen Freundin ja so ein Idiot heute
bin ich der Scheiß Typ ja
jetzt
ist so lustig
ja
wie das Leben so spielt die letzte rote
die letzte rote die mache ich die Grünen
machen was Protest nicht
warum seid ihr so viele habt ihr allein
nichts drauf
boah hatte Ansage von der rosane Frage
ja es ist tatsächlich so dass wir
zusammen mehr drauf haben ja aber
vielleicht ergibt das alles zusammen
eine lustige Person genau und die
versuchen wir irgendwann mal zu bilden
dann Apple
okay
ihr müsst die grüne beantragen kommen
die ist mit Liebe gemacht
nein
immer noch nicht
jung zu bleiben so jung zu bleiben
so da noch nichts sexistisches gekommen
ist sag ich einfach mal hemmungslosen
Sex
nein purer Zufall Glück immer gute Laune
haben glaube ich klappe
sehr gut
fehlgeschlagen ist versuchst du genau
daher vielleicht diese
Vogelscheiße der Witz ist daneben
gelaufen
welchen Witz
ich geil
und wir haben noch keine grüne Frage für
Dance
nette Frage
eine nette Frage für Tennis könnt ihr ja
jetzt Fragezeichen
das ist natürlich schlimm ja es ist
furchtbar oder ganz schlimm ja ich
glaube er ist so der erste Mensch vor
mir sogar noch der Diabetes erkrankt
ja aber ich bin ja jetzt in der
schokoreha ich bin ja jetzt gerade dabei
das wieder okay mit was
muss ich dann in die Reha wegen dem
Alkohol ist zwar erst das alles blöd
okay
okay vielen Dank
schalten Sie auch nächste Woche ein wenn
es wieder heißt irgendwas mit klickst du
wir machen sie bei Amazon wenn euch
dieses Video gefallen hat dann gefällt
euch sicher auch dass Fragen Lotto mit
waititi indem sie die gewichtige Frage
beantworten wer ist eigentlich der
süßeste von den dreien und auch nicht
von schlechten Eltern ist das fragen was
du mit Bülent indem ich in ein wenig
Kitzler mit der Frage ob sein Humor denn
nicht zu brav sei also entscheidet euch
jetzt links oder rechts die Qual der
Wahl ähm Spaß hat der in jedem Fall und
ansonsten bis dann